but what we need to discuss is why
prince andrew prince andrew
of the royal family
why
he was raping women
and
said no this is no longer alleged he's
i guess it's technically alleged if it's
a settlement yeah okay so he settled
on a raping women case with virginia
gouffrey
who said that i guess she he raped her
he raped her now technically
uh she would be trafficked for sex
uh she would be i think 17 when he had
sex with her
which disgustingly is legal in in the uk
step it up over there yeah come on right
you can't just go 18. like stop just 17
in new york so it's 17 years yeah we got
to go over there yeah we got to go
make it make it 25 bro what are we doing
right now
what are we right now what are we right
now i have to calculate my wife
now
that seems about right
[Laughter]
okay but we're good we're good
old ass woman i got
yeah man my old lady old lady out here
they just keep getting older they'd be
getting old as hell celebrating my
girl's birthday like are you sure
celebrating
you couldn't be born on a leap year
february 29th oh i'm going on leap day
off come on
okay prince andrew prince andrew yeah so
he's settled explain
the details of this settlement mark
yeah you love these because apparently
he donated money to a charity he did not
give money to virginia goofy looks like
he did both ah yeah so
just if i could say this is a woman he
said he's never even met so technically
he is giving or the royal family no i
think he said he doesn't remem remember
meeting her well
well [ __ ] because if we're just giving
money to people we don't remember no i
think he said he did meet him you raped
me
wait who raped you prince andrew
have you just given away money to people
you don't even remember oh yeah i mean
there is a picture of them together
that's what i'm saying so he says he
doesn't remember i got you got you but
then he goes i guess something must have
happened yeah so i want to so according
to new york times the amount that
well new york times when they reported
this [ __ ] mad shade what they do they
put the age rate after the yeah
yeah as you should as you should
the amount that prints andrew 61 will
pay muscu frey is confidential the party
said a joint statement attached to the
filing andrew also intends to make a
substantial donation to charity in
support of victim's rights what the [ __ ]
is substantial give me the substance
yeah i don't know but like why why do
you think that if you donate donate more
to the girl you raped yeah don't don't
you didn't rape the charity you raped a
girl donate to the girl you raped
why are you giving money to another
organization undisclosed amount
like what does that do that's just a pr
thing huh like a pr thing yeah but don't
you think it'd be better pr if
the girl got more money yeah but it's
like the difference between a girl
getting 10 million and 11 million is
like all right whatever i'm gonna give
money to the girl and then the charity
that a million to women's rights give it
to the girl brother the women's rights
they didn't have to deal with nothing
maybe she requested it
she could have requested it well she
should give it to them herself
say i don't want this rape money you
know what i want to give all that money
to women's rights it's kind of corny of
her
to accept a settlement
talk to him it's a low recording because
she has been talking about for a really
long time she wants justice
justice she wants justice can i defend
her no no let this out and then defend
her yes i i i personally and this is my
personal opinion i think justice comes
in a criminal
like you can't pay for my justice
but that's just on me interesting all
right guys we're taking a break from
this exclusive patreon clip because i
gotta tell you about the best wallet in
the business
and these wallets are made by exer very
simple okay why are you flapping your
wallet these days those days are over
you're not george costanza you are you
you're a successful man or woman out
there achieving your goals and you need
a wallet that matches you need
extra do you see how easy those cards
popped up right there out the wallet you
need id
of course you need id you need an idea
to do anything these you need your vax
card
boom ready to go in your wallet okay
anything you could possibly need
is right here
and extra's got the best goddamn wall in
the business and let me tell you
something if you thought for a second
that i was going to be telling you about
extra wallets and you were going to have
to pay full price you got your goddamn
mind
you're out your
goddamn mind okay matter of fact they
gonna need to make some more room in
these extras for all the money i'm gonna
be [ __ ] saving you once i drop this
goddamn promo code i get excited
i get excited about the best wallet in
the business
did you know they got a little thing on
this thing if you lose it it finds it
key tracker that's what it's called and
they got the old nerd ass and it got the
idea the copy protection and the guy did
listen my point is extra is the truth
and i know you're wondering whoa what if
it goes out of battery solar god damn
solar charging in the sun oh [ __ ] yeah
go to the sun once or twice they're not
ready they're not ready this is what
you're gonna do extra.com use the promo
code flagger in the checkout you're
getting 30 off your order now let's get
back to that uh patreon episode you can
get the full episode at patreon.com
join the [ __ ] army right now
you probably figure i'm not going to win
a criminal case because they got all the
money of the royal family behind me the
most powerful lawyers in the country can
just if nothing else bleed me dry
financially i will not win the cards are
stacked completely against me let me at
least get some money and the stain on
this guy will be even if he doesn't
serve jail time
he's settling he probably [ __ ] raped
this little guilty in the court of
public opinion because he's donating
money to the accuser yes but if it goes
to trial doesn't some of the details
come out
but here's the thing she must know that
there's no proof and you can't prove
maybe there's no way to prove that
one he didn't know her age
and two that he paid
yes right like if there's no way to
actually prove there's a transaction he
just thinks damn this little girl likes
me
she must be of age she's at the club
with us
or my friends introduced not like she
was like hi i'm 14 years old nice to
meet you my buddy jeff said it was cool
like it's his friend from whatever
whatever no i don't think yeah i don't
think this is what actually happened but
there's possible deniability
he can say that in court oh i didn't
know where's the transaction proof but
giving the money to us is guilty so now
that's a stain on the royal family yeah
and how do you prove you got raped years
ago there to have proof that you got
raped is damn near impossible and
low-key the royal family got to pay for
it
the royal family yeah they're coming
from the royal family they cut them off
apparently i don't think they cut them
off that's again pr
they're like oh we cut him off i
guarantee you he's still getting taken
care of oh it's one of these things
that's like
you get cut off okay but you still got a
castle somewhere yeah you still got a
what is it called trust funds yeah no
but they cut the red head off with
shorty and this is the first got bread
he got a deal from netflix for christmas
but i'm saying he's making his own money
now like he's not making notes yeah
he's making his own money based on the
fact that he's the prince so it's like
if he was if if being royal and then
being cut off meant that society views
you as a nobody then you're really cut
off but you still get all the equity of
being the prince so you can go do a
production deal with netflix even though
you've never produced anything in your
life and the rams let this [ __ ]
in the locker room after the super bowl
um for what for what right you know what
football was until six months ago you
guys yeah
yeah i am hayden yeah you hate me i am
hating [ __ ] you support that little
[ __ ]
yeah why you married a black woman okay
i got you you didn't you didn't think of
that but i got no no that's what i was
there i just forgot her name but what
blackboard it is crazy that the royal
family's like hey you on your own
but prince andrew because he played ball
we got your back yeah we got your back
and then and because with the what's his
name harry he kind of defied everybody
they're like yo [ __ ] you you're terribly
good he's
married a black girl and had a baby and
they're like get the [ __ ] out of this
castle
prince andrew raped women and they're
like at least you did it here yeah
at least drive you like a cool
[ __ ] yeah
and make sure they're white
100 apparently they so like she filed a
lawsuit
six months ago
basically putting all of these
allegations into the court of law and
then prince andrew this is the thing
that came up like a month ago tried to
get it dismissed and the judge said nah
you can't dismiss it uh british judge or
american judge uh doesn't matter judge
kaplan i don't know
kaplan yeah i'm gonna go with america
sounds american to me yeah yep so
basically was like yeah we're not gonna
dismiss it you can't dismiss it and then
a month after the judge said you can't
dismiss it is when they were like all
right let's what's the number that makes
sense
so it seems like she was trying to
pursue it in the court of law yeah okay
that makes you feel better about it yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i i honestly think that that girl
is um
has the right intentions
she's been the most vocal
like she's married she's living in
australia
bro she's like she's an artist
that art is fire we got to get that in
this mural bro we gotta get this to get
it in the studio with the snake less
wexner in it
we need that we need to figure out what
les wexler is i might get a chest piece
that's my [ __ ] evil bruh that
[ __ ] might be evil that's the
most evil guy he might be evil he got
all the [ __ ] yo where are you the guy
who knows where the bodies are buried
that's the guy bro that's the crypt
keeper he knows how you know we need to
pull up
hey
that's ohio what state is that yeah you
got some cuddy smoke though i think
cuddy's from there
your [ __ ] comedy show all right get
out of here bro we can exchange vows
[Music]
just dress up in [ __ ] wedding gowns
okay lesbo marry each other man love you
kid cudi
what up people you just watched a clip
from our weekly patreon episode you can
support the flagrancy you can support
this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
you